Sam says, could you do automated check-ins?
Absolutely.
Absolutely could do automated check-ins.
I do think the phone call goes a long way,
like just checking in with them.
I think if you want to do an automated check-in,
maybe like half the time, and maybe half the time
you do a call, maybe you have it set up.
The second and the fourth week, it's an email.
And it's like, hey, whatever, whatever.
The second week is this email, it's already scripted out.
This one's this email, and maybe every month it changes.
Totally.
I think the other two weeks though, you need to call them.
I think at least specifically for this first
three to six month contract, you need to call them
and you need to let them know that you care,
that you're paying attention, that you're focused on them.
Now, after that first contract's done
and you've signed the new one, that's when you can go,
okay, what parts of this can we automate?
That's where they're so much easier to work with.
Like, dude, the only time I even talk to my clients,
let me give you an example, my artificial grass client,
I've had him since 2021, okay, like the first of 2021.
So I guess we're coming up on two years.
I don't talk to this guy, like we just keep doing business.
Now, I talked to him today.
Well, he didn't answer.
I called him today, but it wasn't to talk about business,
it was because I needed a quote on a townhome
that I just bought.
And I had his little patch of grass and it looks like shit.
I'm like, hey, let me get my guy to give me a quote.
So they just become so much easier.
Once you gain that trust, Sam, or anyone else asking,
once you gain that trust during that first
three to six month period, things ease up,
but take your time, be okay doing things.
I heard this once, I loved it.
Be okay doing things that are unscalable
because sometimes the unscalable things
are the things that allow you to scale.
I know that sounds kind of weird.
Let me say that one more time.
Be okay doing the unscalable things
because sometimes those unscalable things
are the very things that allow you to scale.
What I mean by that is it's not scalable
to checking every one of your clients every Friday.
I get it, okay?
However, sometimes those things that aren't scalable,
they show the business owner, hey,
I know this isn't scalable.
He can't possibly do this to everyone.
And that's the reason why it's so effective.
So I would tell you during those first three to six months,
that first contract, be okay making a phone call.
And in the back of your mind, okay,
let's set up some automation so that once he or she
signs that second contract, boom,
it's just an automated system, okay?
Great question.